you had that breakfast club interview a
few years ago where you talked about
ownership
and that [ __ ] really like resonated with
me
so that was that was my purpose i wanted
it to resonate yeah man because you know
like
i've done radio for so long and
you have worked for
you know the i hearts the
conglomerates of the of the radio
industry
and uh at the end of last year i walked
away from like terrestrial radio in a
sense of working for anybody and just
started my own syndicated radio show
starting my own podcast and now i'm on
hella markets and all those companies
like i heart you know like i'm a partner
and you own it right i own it uh you
know what i'm saying like i still and
i'm still on reel 923 in la but i'm on
real 923 in la every night on my own
terms and it promotes everything you're
doing that you own a hundred percent and
i don't i don't i don't work for them
you know what i'm saying i used to work
for iheart you know i mean my checks
used to say i heart media
and and you know i kind of
feel like like
that interview you did man was a lot of
inspiration for me so i just want to
give you props man because that's some
real [ __ ] like you can't really say
you're a boss
unless you're
really a boss unless you're actually
about unless you actually have employees
you know what i'm saying somebody unless
you actually have a business unless you
lose the money to make money unless you
know unless you're taking that risk that
gamble that this is yours
you know unless you're a founder
something that came from your brain yeah
you know something that inspires you and
that you stood behind fearlessly